the birds who occasionally come to his
garden
are david's only visitors living alone
with progressive multiple sclerosis
life wasn't easy before the pandemic now
it's even harder
i don't see anybody for weeks months
sometimes
no content whatsoever my two cats
they're my family and it's a distraction
from
the worry and it's a constant worry
of how on earth do i cope his loneliness
has been compounded by new financial
pressures
david receives legacy benefits and
unlike those on universal credit
did not get the weekly increase of 20
pounds that the government introduced
last year
bigger heating bills and the extra cost
of food delivery
are pushing him further into debt i will
only have one hot meal a day
even if my stomach is rumbling um i
i tend to eat in the evenings um
so i live on basically tea
throughout the day it is really really
really hard
new research by the disability benefits
consortium has found the pandemic has
left the majority of vulnerable people
on benefits like esa and job seekers
allowance
struggling to meet additional costs the
consortium which represents more than
100 disability organizations
have called on the chancellor to
maintain the 20-pound weekly increase to
universal credits for at least
another year and to extend it to other
benefits at the same time
today the work and pension secretary
said the idea of extending the uplift
beyond april
was under consideration discussions are
still ongoing
uh with other parts of government but on
the question of extending the increased
support to legacy benefits as well
she was less clear disabled people have
faced
significantly increased costs during the
pandemic
so they should have had some extra help
i'm not aware
specifically of extra costs that would
have been unduly incurred
but i i hear what you say
but this conservative mp thinks the
government has no option but to act
yes the 20 pound uplift should apply to
legacy
benefits as well colleagues you know
right across the board
whether as individuals whether as groups
of of mps
are making that you know you know both
to the dwp
and also treasury as well david like
hundreds of thousands of others like him
will hope the government listens to
those views ahead of next month's budget
but he's not optimistic they just don't
hear
the pleads for help that have gone out
there are times where i think
i'm not sure how much longer i can
continue doing this
tom rayner sky news westminster